you know what this music means it's
fortnight update time hello and welcome
to Playstation grenade we are about to
hit week 11 in fortnight chapter 2
season 2 and all the secret plots are
taking shape so sit your butt down for
10 minutes use code at amaru to keep
this series going and let's look at all
the map changes in the new update
[Music]
as always I checked up on our Lord and
Savior Graham in his radio tower he's
seen a few things this week but he's
doing well
turns out he's a Travis Scott fan who'd
have thought that but this isn't the
biggest news of the week this is the
biggest news of the week hit it hot
watch chapter 2 has finally arrived
after so many false dawns you can find
this by going past the bunker close to
the box factory here's the back story I
don't know about you but my two favorite
updates in the first chapter of the game
were the chair house in the Old West
world and the sacred Hut we watched for
months on end when chapter 2 started the
chairs somehow made it to the island and
were put in storage at the docks
suddenly and excruciatingly ly slowly
they began to move around the island at
the opposite side of the aisle at the
very same time a flatbed truck from the
log jam location began to move in the
opposite direction with wooden pallets
aboard they raced at breakneck speeds
for the next three updates and then
disaster struck they collided and their
loads were thrown everywhere cut back to
this week and now see the progression
the police have arrived to cordon off
the area and check for survivors but as
we know the real story is at the foot of
this incline the change is subtle but
the cleanup has already begun a dump
truck has started to remove unwanted
items like chairs and old bits of wood
and the Hut is already beginning to be
rebuilt
I don't want to get our collective hopes
up here but in the game's code this
update is called hot watch I think it's
time to get hyped to watch a hut slowly
build over weeks and months yeah it
doesn't sound great when I put it like
that well I don't care if you're with me
with this pointless update let's fill
this chat with hot watch forever
now let's break open the underpinning
story of the season by looking at the
agency if you can remember all the way
back to week three the meeting room for
Midas and his Eagle pals was changed
someone stole my does his golden chair
who would do such a thing that thing
must have weighed a metric ton the
following update we saw a kayak take the
chair across the river to a vehicle
waiting in the bushes like a getaway
driver then the boat was hidden from
sight and the blue car raced away they
didn't go too far stopping at the last
house in salty springs at this point we
were unsure of their position in the
ghost versus shadow saga but a poster
outside in the trash let us know they
didn't like Midas too much the chair and
sat for a month in an upstairs room was
this simply a case of theft or was
something happening here this update we
know a little bit more well sort of
remember when I said it was pure gold
and that chair was heavy well I meant it
look at this mess the pressure on the
floorboards has given way and the chair
and table are now downstairs right let's
get serious for a second if this was you
you stole that chair and now it had
broken through the ceiling of your house
what would you do next do your best now
to predict the thief's next movements
I'll be lurking in the comments to reply
out of nowhere the next update is the
story that keeps on giving the misfit
bears and the genome warriors who would
have thought back in the winter time
when the misfits began their uprising
that things would go so far when I first
saw the misfits plotting in the snow I
knew they must be eliminated but they
survived my first attack and took
control of a secret bunker in the forest
there they decided to take a prisoner
Gandalf
ok ok I'll say his full name you guys
named him I will give him that respect
Gandalf
keemstar Jerome the genome yep that name
is weird as hell I can't believe I have
to say every update but that was the
deal what was I saying
oh yeah the prisoner well the genome
warriors built an army outside and all
rushed B to take
control of the situation turning the
tables on the Bears but only eliminating
one of them to show they were the real
deal but they were casualties on both
sides rip also last update I asked you
to name the misfit leader and the winner
is Nick furry you get it answer play on
Nick Fury Gigi Marvel fans somehow
though some of you guys watching helped
the misfits break free and now back to
today's update nobody is in this room
except the guy eating honey and the
story has been elevated to the
battlefield the genome army vs. the
misfit bears four months of story
development leading to this now is the
time to decide your allegiance misfits
our genome who will win this epic battle
of the ages well nobody will if you go
in game now you can click on both sides
and disarm them this war is going to end
in a peace treaty remember to Like and
subscribe for more on this awesome
storyline in next update
the next change on our map is by
everyone's favorite billionaire the Iron
Man Tony sat dormant for three months
but the introduction of a pair of
Christmas themed glasses brought him to
life and we saw him move his head and
look out over the ocean over the next
eight weeks the pipe man stood up
claimed his trusty walking stick and
began to walk around the edge of the map
right now he's chillax in he's taken in
the view of the island and is even
crossing his legs is that relaxed but
here's the thing to note is it is this a
coincidence of was he looking in the
exact same location when he first turned
his head is he trying to show us
something
that's not here yet something in the
distance I can't decide I need your help
we originally thought he was going to
Eva this mess of pipes or this structure
in the marshland but as of right now
he's taking part in social distancing
and staying away from everyone can we
just take a second here to admire the
footsteps he leaves behind
I'm a sucker for attention to detail in
video games and I adore these little
marks in the ground I know that don't
impress everyone but I love little
updates like this very impressive work
unnamed epic a set designer person keep
up that great work other small updates
can be found at the no sweat Insurance
Building who have slowly begun to fill
their offices with more items at present
we are still waiting for the famous
diorama to make it over so I'll keep
checking back as we are talking about no
sweat though have you noticed the areas
the signs can be found
they are around Pleasant Park frenzy
farm Holly hedges is this a sign that
the areas will be protected from the
event at the end of the season or does
the show where we'll be targeted for
destruction please let me know your
thoughts unless piece together this
mystery Oh a tiny but very important
update risky reals now has its Pio I
named back on the map it's officially a
named area again I don't know why this
made me happy but it did so I hope it
did for you too another update sees a
new mode tested this week which removes
building and weapons from the game this
will be our party Meetup
it's unsure how it will be implemented
but if like me and you hate people
deliberately ruining meetups this new
function could
by that and your fashion shows our games
of hide-and-seek won't be ruined by
people with ttv in their name thinking
that they're an awesome cloud chaser
yeah I have a bit of a grudge let's move
on so between the last update and this
one a very small event happened
an unknown rapper called Travis Scott
Loki visited the island okay he came in
like a wrecking ball in pink I like that
touch how good was that event well did
you see all the secrets on Easter eggs
in that show it basically was a
retelling of chapter 1 the entirety of
chapter 1 storyline let's quickly break
it down the event began with a meteor
high in the sky which we all stared at
waiting for it to hit when it did smash
down this time it didn't make a crater
it brought with it a 300-foot man
without nipples but that's a whole other
story
let's not go there the impacts changed
gravity just like the hot rocks did back
in season 4 chapter 1 and just like the
rocket event time was ripped apart as
Travis moved around when we were taken
underwater the skull troopers they were
there to represent the monster which
broke out of the ice and then reappeared
to attempt to break the Nexus to
represent Kevin in this event the meteor
boom box began to spin and explode just
like Kevin did back in the day we miss
you Kevin we then saw a smaller version
of the end event as we raced towards a
black hole and finally to represent our
time in other dimensions we saw the
sacred rift butterfly before returning
home the entire chapter one plot in
eight minutes it was so impressive
if you haven't seen the event or you
want to relive it with that information
I'll link a cinematic version I made at
the end of the video
so I think we're done here there we have
it week 11 chapter 2 season 2 what did I
miss
I'll be in the comments taking notes if
I missed anything they can be ridiculous
to like one person sent me a DM tell me
about the crustaceans and what they did
during the Travis Scott event they did
this they had a really good time
but seriously please keep me updated if
you spot anything I miss on screen now
are the leg ends who've used code a
damaru and sent me a picture on twitter
thanks for rocking my coat I truly
appreciate it you are awesome as always
I'm a little behind on DM as I reply to
all supporters so if you haven't heard
from me yet please be patient I will get
to you you have my word
at present I've never been supported as
much as I am right now
once again I salute you your legends
I'll shut up now I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade it's been a pleasure
let's do this again sometime
see you very soon
[Music]